Ah cosa state
facendo
scappiamo questa insalata fa schifo
adesso avrà la sua
punizione molto carino come tovaglia Sei
[Musica]
licenziata oh dov'è la
cassaforte No no non sono un ladro sono
un gatto
miao
fregate Allora per chi è
questa no che cosa avete
fatto che
SCH oggi nuova Challenge 24 lavori in 24
ore in ordine alfabetico e iniziamo dal
primo lavoro e nel primo lavoro dovrò
fare la maestra di educazione fisica Se
volete essere salutati guardate il video
fino alla fine E scrivete nei commenti
Qual è stato il vostro momento preferito
e cliccate mi piace e nei prossimi video
saluterò uno di voi scrivete nei
commenti ma ora iniziamo subito la
Challenge chi saranno i miei alunni
questa volta oh no dove saranno finite
Anita Anita Vitale eccoti qua finalmente
anche tu sei un maestro di educazione
fisica Devi aiutarmi Infatti dobbiamo
prendere le cinque stelle per superare
questa Challenge eh però c'è un piccolo
problema Sì mi sono sfuggiti i ragazzi
oh no non dobbiamo Essere licenziati da
questi lavori Altrimenti non supereremo
le Challenge e dobbiamo farne tanti di
lavori Se Scoprono che i ragazzini ci
sono scappati ci licenzieranno Dimmi
dove sono andati lì di dove di
là siamo qua siamo qua guarda Lucy Sto
volando non vi siete nemmeno
Acc e che Che bello e dai Nico Fami un
po' me sull'altalena
via Mi hai fatto andare sto gioc EC
finalment vi sembra il caso
[Applauso]
di li avete riconosciuti sono gli stessi
ragazzini dell'altra Challenge dico e
lcy e sono cattivissimi
cattivissimi proviamo a farli giocare
con la palla Magari riusciamo a farli
calmare Ehi Nico Luzi Guardate Ho una
bolla qua volete giocare è mia è mia
aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspettate Allora prima bisogna
mettersi II punti di partenza perché qua
c'è primo io primo io primo io sono il
primo Vitale Ah tu sei il maestro di
educazione fisica non devi partecipare
alla tall te Lao
io ora Basta vi sequestro la palla visto
che non sapete giocare con la palla vi
sequestro la palla e ora dovrete fare un
percorso vedete tutti questi coni Oh
Anita ma noi non dobbiamo giocare con i
coni Non ce ne frega niente del percorso
fatelo voi due no no no no dovete
seguire il percorso perché io sono la
vostra maestra di educazione fisica e se
non vi faccio fare educazione fisica mi
licenzieranno Facciamo così Chi finisce
per prima il percorso vince questa palla
bello bello Allora sì lo facciamo io
primo Sì ma tanto vinco io non è vero
vinci sempre tu una volta devi far
vincere anche me no non litigate adesso
Andate tutti ai posti di partenza presto
Pronti ai posti di partenza inizia la
gara 3 2 1
via va Io io
io
ahiai oh no si stanno di nuovo
picchiando Questi ragazzi ci sono delle
pezzi arancione mio
fratellino per Dovete continuare il
percorso di qua
dai il tempo stando la
gara questi ragazzini sono
difficilissimi da gestire stanno
distruggendo tutto attenzione bisogna
controllarli ha vinto lei non è
giusto ha vinto Lucy Questo vuol dire
che la palla la vince Lucy Ehi Lucy
Ecco la palla per
te guarda ni Tu non ce l'hai questa
veloce Io comunque anche se stanno
litigando stanno facendo educazione
fisica vedo che si divertono Sì forse la
lezione sta funzionando In effetti
perché finché fanno educazione fisica
Sto facendo il mio lavoro Speriamo nelle
cinque stelle e che si stanchino anche e
che non veniamo licenziati anche un po'
a meelo usare un po' me Ho vinto io
aspetta m'ai spossato eh
[Musica]
eo No Nico non dovevi rubare la palla a
luy non l'hai vinta tu ma la volevo
usare un po' anch'io siamo fratelli
dobbiamo dividerci le cose no ma l'ho
vinta io Sì ora la è sequestrata e non è
di nessuno dei due Adesso magari lo
tengo
io mi hanno preso la palla presa a me
questo è per colpa tua Non è vero sono
Sono loro che non ci fanno giocare bene
adesso ce ne andiamo Sì scappiamo e
sapete Quante stelle vi daranno Zero
andiamo Dove state andando Oh no stanno
scappando dobbiamo recuperarli subito
altrimenti ci licenzieranno Vitale Tu
insegui Prova a recuperarli ragazzi
venite qua Dove state andando No noi
scappiamo da te no ti vogliamo no no do
stare qui lu lu Sem se un colo sei un
colo palla
Pall St facendo
tieni basta Ragazzi
andiamo Oh no ma sono dei pestiferi
questi ragazzi venite qua piano ragazzi
piano Se fate i bravi poi dopo vi do un
gelato voglio io Ahia mi hai fatto male
tiri amogli il pallone Sì
Ah che bello
scappiamo Ahia mi hanno fatto malissimo
Mi hanno tirato le pallonate e anche i
coni ho un'idea per far comportare bene
i ragazzini e fargli fare educazione
fisica così quando torneranno i genitori
non ci licenzieranno ho preso dei giochi
posso tenerli impegnati con questi
giochi ma ora non mi resta che
chiamarli giochi ah eccomi qua dov'è
finito Vitale che fine gli avete fatto
fare Che giochi ci sono Ho un'idea
potete giocare al salto con il sacco
così almeno non potete andare da nessuna
parte bello è giallo sembra
Vitale io posso avere quello rosso va
bene Tieni Ah io voglio quello blu
Allora ok tieni quello blu ma questi
ragazzini guarda lo voglio no non
Iniziate a litigare già voglio io il las
Aspetta almeno li sto tenendo impegnati
così giocheranno e non c r ceneranno
finato Cosa state
facendo scappiamo cosa è
nostra no tornate qua niale ti aspetto
la luce ho Aspetto la luce ci hanno
messo nel sacco letteralmente tutti e
due dobbiamo trovare un modo di tenerli
impegnati altrimenti distruggeranno
tutto qua che altro gioco possiamo
provare Proviamo con il prismi magari
proveranno a prenderlo e rimarranno
impegnati con il Prism proviamo che stai
facendo e stavo vedendo se c'era
qualcosa da mangiare non c'è niente da
mangiare PR Chiam subito una bambina
Lucy Nico venite Guardate che c'ho qui
Cè possiamo possiamo bere ma questi
bicchieri sono bucati non servono niente
è meglio così cade tutto gli facciamo
uno scherzo So io come
chiamarli
[Musica]
[Applauso]
limonata lionata lionata Questo è per te
e questo è per te
mai è
vuoto
scherzo Basta adesso distruggiamo
tutto No
giochi aspettate Aspettate aspettate Ho
ancora un gioco divertenti S
Sì aend regaleresti ok
[Musica]
pri ho vinto nuovamente e basta però
fammi vincere una volta Guarda ho VTO
io
bravissima hai vinto tutti questi giochi
quti giochi sono tutti per te sei
contenta Ehi ma fanno
schifo te lo meriti non mi fai
maiata Andiamo andiamo nella giostra di
Disneyland Sì
Ahia Oh no hanno buttato a terra tutti i
giochi questi ragazzini sono proprio
cattivi e ITI come faremo a prendere
cinque stelle adesso se arrivano i
genitori ci licenzieranno dobbiamo fare
in modo che non si facciano male e che
facciano educazione fisica come facciamo
Eh non lo so Ho un'idea tu sistema i
giochi qua adesso e io provo a fermarli
Nel fare la giostra di Disneyland come
la chiamano loro altrimenti si faranno
male vado subito Ok ciao a dopo E ora
che cosa faccio Devo raccogliere tutto
questo caos che hanno combinato ci sono
anche le uova per terra per fortuna non
si sono rotte
Ah ma non si
rompono Uh ma è divertente questo gioco
Ehi ma questo che gioco
è ho capito Ho un'idea per tenerli
impegnati Anita Anita questa questa è la
giostra di Disney divertentissima posso
farla i No l'hai fatta l'altra volta
Adesso tocca a me un po' Va bene fammi
salire Dammi una mano sì adesso Tirami
su Uh ma non sei fare Maco quello Dai
provaci io CEO riuscita a salire
l'ultima volta eh è sempre ragione tu
Tanto
no Aiutami dai Prendimi la
gamb così così
lui Fermi fermi non potete salire su
quella giotra
Fermi È bellissimo è
bellissimo
vai giù
aspetta il cappellino È bellissimo il
cappellino Oh
no bravissimo
ni Dammi 10 vi avevo detto di non usare
questa giostro è pericolosa arrivata
tardi ma quando inizierete ad ubbidire
come faccio adesso mi è venuta l'idea
Allora praticamente tu tieni questa ok E
io faccio così e li
leghiamo Sì sì sì così stanno
Fermi Non mi piace questo
gioco non funziona così questo gioco
Questo è il gioco di tiro alla fune Ah e
quindi li possiamo tirare con la
fune no no no aspetta sgali sgali Adesso
lo diciamo a mamma no no non dite niente
Non dite niente allora non avevo capito
come funziona questo gioco Allora tieni
Lucy tira la Corda ok E anche tu Nico ok
Questo è il gioco di tiro alla fune
ottima idea Vitale come funziona questo
gioco Nico Lucy dovrete tirare la fune
al mio via e se la bandierina
supererà questo punto e andrà verso Lucy
Avrà vinto Lucy se va verso Nico Avrà
vinto Nico Siete
pronti 3 2 1
via Vinco io bravi Continuate così
stancatevi
non ci
riesco Mi scappa la cacca
però vinco
io Dai
Nico
aspetta troppo sforzo un'altra mamma mia
adesso uso la puzza per
stenderla vai là vai
là Nico cosa
stai Mamma mia
Nico devo vincere Comunque non respiro
ma il mio piano non sta funzionando devo
impegnarmi di
più dai Nick sì Sì Vitale ce l'abbiamo
fatta abbiamo trovato il gioco giusto
per loro perché sono talmente testardi
che nessuno di loro molla la presa e
così sono rimasti impegnati tutto questo
tempo sì e gli abbiamo fatto fare
educazione fisica Quindi abbiamo
ricevuto le cinque stelle abbiamo
passato questo lavoro passiamo subito al
prossimo lavoro 3 2
1 in che lavoro sono adesso Ess
segretaria Chissà di chi sarò segretaria
eh Ma voi avete cliccato mi piace se non
l'avete ancora cliccato cliccate subit
mi
piace perché mi trattano sempre così ma
tu tu sei una nuova segretaria sì
scappa in tempo
scappa ma che cosa sta dicendo scappa mi
sa che non sarà molto facile Questo
lavoro ma devo andare non posso fare in
ritardo Altrimenti mi licenzierà il mio
obiettivo come sempre è ricevere le cin
stelle e non essere licenziata andiamo
subito a conoscere il
capo Buongiorno sono la nuova
segretaria non si bussa soprattutto
quando la signora sta facendo il
controllo per la nuova stagione di moda
Ma insomma lei è la nuova segretaria il
contatto e lei Chi è Io sono Anita la
nuova segretaria sono qua per non essere
licenziata e cioè per prendere C stelle
cioè qua per lavorare per lei Vitale ma
cosa stai facendo dovresti essere anche
tu il segretario con la s e che a me
come S è capitato spazzino e infatti sto
pulendo un po' qui un po' qui deve
essere tutto pulito perché sono molto
esigenti sì stai attento C'è della
polvere
qua un granello di
polvere se Salvi che
puo Ma perché assumiamo soltanto
incompetenza Senti pulisci meglio Guarda
qui hai capito pulisci Sì sì sì subito
subito chiedo scusa chiedo scusa
e adesso è pulito è più pulito adesso
vero è Pito R capiti mai più no no no Le
assicuro che non capiterà mai più E se
come scappa ma oggi è il mio primo
giorno sono la segretaria e non devo
essere licenziata quindi che cosa devo
fare nel mio primo giorno di lavoro Tu
saresti la nuova segretaria ma per
favore non so cosa stia succedendo al
capo a prendere una come te e comunque
devi mandare questi a tutte le aziende
metti questi nel camerino e questa è la
sua borsa Stai attenta alle 8:00 vuole
la colazione
puntuale ok Quindi allora mi sono già
dimenticata cosa dovevo fare siccome lei
è la mia Kappa mi può ripetere che cosa
devo fare per favore può abbassare la
voce Mi sta venendo mal di testa Ok
scusa a me sembra che io sto parlando in
modo sono tranquilla Non lo so comunque
che cosa devo
fare prima di tutto potresti
cambiarti giacchetto blu con la gonna
nera qua siamo in un'agenzia di moda non
accetto queste cose ma che cosa c'è di
male Mi sembra che sono vestita bene
piuttosto hai chiamato Praga e LN
Vuitton Eh no come li devo chiamare
Sbrigati tra poco inizia la sfilata Ok
non c'è tempo da perdere
scatare aiuto ha detto che devo chiamare
frag allito dove li trovo questi numeri
io devo pulire la porta deve essere
tutto pulitissimo e prova a vedere Prova
a vedere l'el telefonico ci do
telefonico Sì sì Sta praticamente tutto
in fondo a sinistra girando a
destra dai corri vestiti dove li devo
mettere il mio borre già non sto capendo
niente Ma là c'è l'assistente proverò a
chiedere a lui Ehi tu tipa vestita male
come ti chiami
Anita Comunque sappi che ti sorveglierà
da questo computer 24 ore su 24 dovrai
essere impeccabile altrimenti ti
licenzierò immediatamente ok ci siamo
intese vuol dire che questo posto è
pieno di videocamere ma non c'è problema
perché io lavorerò tutto il tempo pur di
non essere licenziata Ma che cosa dovevo
fare con questi vestiti o questa borsa
meglio che chiedo all'assistente dov'è
eh Eccolo Ascolta che cosa dobbiamo fare
con questi vestiti ancora non li hai
portati nel camerino Dammi qua faccio io
Mamma mia Tu pensa al suo pranzo Mi
raccomando un'insalata leggera Eh le
piacerà e fa in fretta ok ok un'insalata
un'insalata devo andare subito a
prendere l' installata altrimenti si
arrera il capo andiamo e che cosa Doo
fare chiedere all'assistente ancora qua
non l' hai portato il pranzo Ma tu sei
ovunque Eh conosco tutti i passaggi
segreti qua sono di casa ma sbrigati
quella se non le arriva il pranzo in
tempo ci licenzia tutti io non posso
permettermelo tu magari Sì tieni ti ho
già preparato l'insalata vedrai che le
piacerà Vai vai l'insalata è proprio il
suo piatto preferito Sbrigati Comunque
anche io non posso permettermi di essere
licenziata altrimenti perdo la Challenge
quindi non posso essere licenziata
Grazie per tutti ioi Preziosi consigli
che cos'è questo pranzo è un'insalata Te
l'ho già detto e comunque io ti avrei
licenziato solo per come sei vestita
Guarda lasciamo perdere Vai vai che
tardi qual è il problema di come sono
vestita perché hao non piace come sono
vestita oggi vabbè devo sbrigarmi a
portare il pranzo alla Kappa E eccomi
qua Finalmente quanto ci voleva eh io in
realtà cioè stavo aspettando Vabbè
comunque io sto lavorando per lei ma non
so neanche il suo nome Io sono Demonia
Uh Che nome
Eh
dolce questo è il suo pranzo maang pure
è tagliato finemente come voglio io
Eh sì Sì certo Non ho idea Eh
sì che cos'è quello E questa sarebbe
un'insalata ma in realtà non l'ho presa
cioè non l'ho fatta io non l'ho
preparata io questa E chi doveva farla
l'ho chiesta a te no ma me l'ha dato il
suo assistente ah È impossibile che sia
stato il mio assistente lui lo sa come
voglio io l'insalata e questa è erba Eh
sì erba insalata non la stessa cosa mia
signora sono arrivati gli inviti per
stasera ma cosa hai fatto un'insalata
così al nostro
capo come sa io ma ma come ti sei
permessa tuoi farci licenziare tutti per
caso mia signora la perdoni adesso le
porterò il pranzo giusto Scusi Scusi era
stato lui a dmi l' insalata è stato lui
signora non vorrà ascoltare una che è
arrivata stamattina e che si veste in
questo modo Spero Sai cosa ti dico
questa insalata fa schifo adesso avrà la
sua
punizione Ma lo sai che quasi quasi il
verde ti dona forza tuti se
riunione
[Musica]
prego
quell'assistenza
sono proprio arrabbiata oggi come tutti
i giorni ma oggi un pochino di più
Eccomi eccomi qua Eccomi qua allora ho
riordinato tutti i documenti che mi
aveva
[Musica]
richiesto Riordina li nuovamente e mia
signora mi chiedono per l'invito di
stasera alla sfilata di moda cosa faccio
confermo conferma Ovvio sì sì
confermiamo C saremo a dovevi farlo già
5 minuti fa Eh sì lo so Mi scusi Questa
è la tua borsa prego questa sfilata deve
essere perfetta Io ho un nome che va
rispettato ok Ha ragione ragione Ha
deciso che abito usare oggi glielo
dovevo portare io eh Un momento finisco
di riordinare i documenti e glielo porto
subito e mi aveva chiesto di scegliere
l'abito Ora glielo porto subito Arrivo
subito veloce ma come ha potuto prendere
come segretaria una così ma ha visto
come si veste ma per favore Sì sì sì sì
è bella sfilata di stasera ci saremo Sì
la signora Demonia ci sarà avrà il suo
abito migliore Mi raccomando il posto in
prima fila eh prenotato Ecco grazie
Buona serata A stasera Ah signora ho
prenotato è tutto pronto per stasera Oh
Dimenticavo Ecco È arrivato il nuovo
prototipo degli occhiali li provi poi
farò sapere cosa ne
pensa troppo grandi e li facciamo subito
cambiare Ma mi spieghi perché ha scelto
una segretaria così perché io amo
licenziare le persone Eccomi eccomi Ecco
il vestito le piace vestito che ho
scelto è
bellissimo molto carino come tovaglia
lei metterebbe mai una cosa del genere
Sì è
bellissimo lo stile non le appartiene la
lasci stare lo porti immediatamente via
Ma che cos'è che non va questo vestito
l' userei alla cena con i parenti eh
senta Forse è il caso che si rilassi un
po' le facciamo fare non so un qualcosa
uno snack Sì per favore il mio letto
caldo Ah no anzi un caffè con latte
ovviamente senza lattosio Lo sapete che
a me fa male Mi raccomando non troppo
caldo però neanche troppo freddo sì eh
una via di mezzo Mi raccomando ci
pensiamo ok no ci penso io ci penso io
così almeno non verò licenziata ci penso
io vado subito vengo a darti una mano è
meglio che controlli Arriv senza
lattosio gli do l'ultima possibilità ma
se sbaglierà di nuovo era licenziata Ah
che
gioia caffè caffè caffè Dov'è il caffè
Ok Ecco la tazza Ecco la macchinetta del
caffè Perfetto Adesso mi manca solo il
latte Ah eccoci qua Allora hai fatto
avrai capito che una delle prime regole
con la signora Demonia è ascoltare
Allora il latte bisogna hai già messo il
caffè Sì ora devo mettere il latte senza
senza lattosio Sei sicura Sì ha detto
senza lattosio ma tu prima perché invece
dell'insalata mi hai dato un po' di erba
del giardino Ah dovresti imparare a non
prendertela con chi è sopra di te
insomma io io valgo molto di più Ecco
che antipatico Senti lasciami lavorare
in pace senza lattosio Ok è questo sì sì
sì sì
sì perfetto vado subito a portarglielo
benissimo e ricordale mi raccomando è
senza lattosio che senò sta malissimo La
signora e noi non vogliamo questo Giusto
Fammi ricontrollare senza lattosio Sì
Sen Adesso sarà licenziata sicuramente
Oh sì caro Tutto bene per la sfilata di
stasera è tutto Ok più o meno Dai ci
sentiamo Baci baci Eccomi eccomi qua con
il suo caffè latte senza lattosio Era
ora
poi mi darà cin stelle Ah buono Grazie e
potrei avere cinque stelle vedremo se
dopo la sfilata di moda andrà tutto bene
ok Devo resistere ancora un po' in
questo lavoro però hai recuperato con
questo caffè veramente buono Meno male
ce la posso fare che cosa posso fare per
lei adesso sì una cosa potresti farla
dovresti chiamare il mio amico Giorgio
armadi e dire che è tutto a posto per
stasera e che sarò più splendida che mai
Ok lo chiamo
subito mia signora fuori c'è la
limousine che la attende ci hanno
chiesto di arrivare un po' prima per
essere lì in prima fila la limousine è
pronta più o meno Se mi lasciate qualche
secondo arrivo subito ma che cos'è
questa putta Eh magari la padrona ha
cambiato profumo no signora deve essere
stato
lui a fare cosa
io Se permettete Vado via un secondo
Vitale te la sei fatta addosso è
così Che vergogna non c'è più rispetto
si può stare qua dentro che puzza cosa
hai fatto Vitale vado a vedere se la
signora sta bene Ha detto che sei stato
tu Beh effettivamente La sento anch'io
questa puzza
ma non sono stato io e non ho nemmeno le
scarpe sporche da dove può venire Vitale
Devi aiutarmi la k è cattivissima ho
paura che verremo licenziati tutti e due
Questa volta non supereremo la Challenge
è sempre arrabbiata Sì me ne sono
accorto mi ha sgridato un sacco di volte
mi ha fatto pulire i vetri otto volte
solo stamattina E a me ha versato
l'insalata in testa l'insalata in testa
ma era condita Eh non lo so No era senza
dita EB meglio così Sen ma secondo me
quello cattivo È l'assistente dobbiamo
stare attenti all'assistente allora che
succede qua siamo in ritardissimo la
limusina è già arrivata sta aspettando
da mezz'ora fuori dal cancello Sì anche
il suo amico stilista sto aspettando eh
Dobbiamo andare Ma dov'è la capa
qualcuno mi ha dato il Lat con l'art
Asio adesso si spiega perché sto così
male io non lo
digerisco sei stata tu signora gliel'ha
messo lei latte lo vissero con lei come
mi sei permessa Come hai fatto a
sbagliare Anita No no no nell'etichetta
c'era chiaramente scritto senza lattosio
lo giuro non non sono stata io che
vergogna io la licenzierei Sì dovresti
essere licenziata Per questo Oh no Sei
stata tu a darmi il latte con lattosio
Sei
licenziata Oh no Questo vuol dire che
abbiamo fallito la Challenge eh Tu sì io
ancora non sono stato licenziato Aspetta
un momento io sono sicura di non aver
messo nessun latte con lattosio
nell'etichetta cera chiaramente scritto
senza lattoso Sei stato tu a confermarmi
che era senza lattoso e perché etichetta
diceva così e basta leggere Se solo
avessi un modo di provare che io ho
messo il latte senza
lattosio aspetta sbaglio o tu K mi hai
detto che questo ufficio è pieno di
videocamere di sorveglianza Brava No no
no chi te l'ha detta questa cosa non è
vero insomma com'è possibile andiamo a
guardare le camere di sorveglianza Sì
controlliamo le subito così vedrà che io
ho messo il latte senza lattosio E va
bene andiamo a controllare le camere di
sorveglianza e chiunque sia stato sarà
licenziato spazzino da quattro soldi
devo licenziare anche te Perché che ho
fatto questa volta poi esci
[Musica]
immediatamente quella era l'insalata che
mi ha versato in
testa controlliamo immediatamente le
telecamere e Facciamola finita questa
storia sì prego prego è tutto pulito
Adesso non vedo l'ora di vedere che cosa
si vede dalle
videocamere io sono sicura di aver messo
quella senza
lattosio cosa ci facevi nella cucina da
solo no no no no ma quello non sono io è
incredibile quanto mi somigli
[Musica]
Eh ho capito ho capito sei stato tu hai
sostituito le etichette con la toose
senza laota perché volevi farmi
licenziare No non sono stato io Tu non
hai idea di quanto sia importante per me
questa sfilata Eh va bene sono stato io
lei non si merita tutto il successo che
ha la verità è che la sfilata ci dovevo
andare io ma che ci dovevi fare tu alla
sfilata Ma ti sei visto non parlare
tu signora frego L'ho fatto per il suo
bene vai via non ti voglio vedere mai
più me la pagherai Sì tu me la pagherai
vai non siamo licenziati lui è
licenziato Ti chiedo scusa non è colpa
tua Non dovevo dubitare di te ma adesso
come faccio io adesso ho la sfilata Eh
devo trovare una soluzione Devo trovare
una soluzione il prima possibile Ho
un'idea che idea tienila distratta per
un momento devo andare a prendere una
cosa importante eh distratta Eh si
distragga un secondo allora praticamente
in questi casi ci sono un paio di
opzioni da fare la prima è avere tanta
carta igienica perché vabbè insomma non
c'è bisogno che lo spiego il motivo però
comunque poi poi magari può far benere
un po' di acqua calda perché aiuta un
pochettino acqua calda tipo la borsa
dell'acqua calda oppure la terza cosa
che è quella più semplice quella più
effettiva Tra l'altro e lasciarsi andare
uno si lascia
andare Certo è un po' una soluzione Un
po' Eccomi qua ho preso il mio libro La
città stregata vi ricordate che le altre
volte ci ha aiutato con le parole
segrete Allora apriamolo subito e
vediamo qual è la parola segreta per
questo video Ecco questa è la parola
segreta traduc etela anche voi andate
alla pagina dell'alfabeto segreto
traducete questa parola Credo di aver
capito cosa devo fare per salvare la
situazione Torno subito continua a
tenerla
distratta provi provi a respirare
un 1 2
3 sì Proviamo così a respirare
respiriamo
insieme no no no no tenga tenga tenga
tutto dentro perché cioè nel senso provi
provio a non stare troppo sto zitto ecco
qua bevo subito questa Mi farò bene S
benissimo È
calda Oh come si sente molto meglio Ah
grazie funzionato sì Quindi ora puoi
andare alla sfilata di moda Ah sì forza
forza È tutto pronto vero Sì è tutto
pronto e la stanno aspettando con la
limousin aspetti ma prima si lascia C
stelle Certo che vi lascio cin stelle
salvar
Grazie mille Adesso vado prego prego
veloce veloce ce l'abbiamo fatta è stato
difficilissimo questo lavoro Ora ci
manca il terzo lavoro pronti 3 2
1 nuovo video 24 lavori nella vita reale
in ordine alfabetico e ora siamo
poliziotti fatto sì sono Vidale Chi è
che c'è eh chi mi raccomando se volete
essere salutati cliccate mi piace qua
guardate il video fino alla fine
scrivete nei commenti Qual è stato il
vostro momento
preferito Ma ora dove dovremmo andare
per il nostro primo lavoro Cosa ci fate
ancora qua Ah siete appena arrivati già
state combinando danni dalla centrale
c'è stato detto che c'è un crimine che è
successo in città dobbiamo raggiungerli
andiamo siamo già in ritardo ogni minuto
è prezioso seguiamo lei nonmi puntare la
torcia andiamo Scusa Sì andiamo anche
perché il nostro obiettivo è non essere
licenziati a ricevere le cinque stelline
Ah Togli via quelle manette che ho paura
che mi arresti dai
riuscito a infiltrar in questa casa e
adesso da bravo ladro quale sono Ruberò
tutti i
gioielli vediamo un po' Uh una
cassaforte
vediamo
no come si
fa ma non
funziona Vabbè l' aprirò dopo vediamo
cos'altro c'è di valore Eh questo no
questo cosa è
Uh Questo è un play button
d'oro questo è d'oro questo Barà
tantissimo sono
[Musica]
ricco
Ah Sono quasi pronta per uscire Mi manca
solo indossare i miei splendidi
gioielli Oh
Dov'è la
cassaforte Oh no devo immediatamente
chiamare la
polizia pronto è successo un fatto
gravissimo
Sì arrivate immediatamente
Eccoci siete qua più veloci di una
puzzetta siamo arrivati allora cosa è
successo Non potete capire che cosa è
successo Che cosaa è successo Se lo
possiamo capire Allora ce ne andiamo
andiamo via Ok andiamo
Arrivederci CIA Vi prego vi prego ok
sono spariti i miei gioielli Erano qua
nella cassaforte col codice
11 e poi è sparito anche il mio adorato
Play
button quindi si tratta del crimine di
un furto Dobbiamo scoprire chi è il
ladro ottimo agente Anita avrà dei punti
in più perché questa è un'ottima
informazione però signora anche lei 11 1
1 mette una una un po' più difficile
tipo 1 2 3 4 eh Stai dicendo è più
difficile allora eh La prima cosa da
fare quali sono sentiamo un po' dobbiamo
cercare degli indizi per vedere dove pui
l'altro beniss per esempio eh Se ci sono
degli impronte delle impronte delle
impronte E allora Dividiamoci tu agente
Anita vai di là e tu agente Vitale da
quella parte Cerchiamo le impronte par E
tu dove vai invece e io sarò qua
contraddire il capo Vai aare farò un un
come si dice
Ecco quello per favore gente mi haa lei
allora innanzitutto che cos'è un play
batton perché io non ho capito ma come
gente è il premio per chi raggiunge un
milione di iscritti Ma quindi lei fa
video su YouTube no Wow Ma è famosa mi
faccia un autografo qua sulla schiena
scriva c'è una penna Vabbè lo facciamo
dopo lei L'importante è che adesso si
rilassi e che non si faccia prendere dal
panico perché quando ci sono i ladri i
ladri fanno venire la Cer i ladri
doval scalma Allora respiri su e giù su
e giù Ecco qua di T giro la testa basta
eh andiamo a nasconderci tanto i miei
agenti St stanno Lavor il ladro potrebbe
essere ancora nelle vicinanze Aspettate
un momento E tu a che ora ti sei accorta
che il ladro aveva rubato tutto ecco beh
io stavo entrando qua perché dovevo
uscire per una cena con amici Le 19:30
io0 am aspetta aspetta aspetta E io non
mangio parl di questa cena di mangiare
abbiamo ricevuto la chiamata alle
19:31 che ora era l'ultima volta che hai
visto i tuoi gioielli cioè la tua cazza
forte e il tuo Play button ottima
domanda gente alle
19:25 dovevo metterli ma dovevo andare
un secondo in bagno e quindi ho
aspettato quindi alle 19:25 Tu li hai
visti alle 19:31 ci hai chiamato Questo
vuol dire che il ladro ha rubato verso
le
19:28 quindi il ladro potrebbe essere
ancora qua in
casa aiut andiamoci Chiam la polizia
amci siamo noi la polizia Allora
cerchiamolo non facciamoci prendere dall
dal panico
allora chi
cerca No vabbè non è il momento tutti
insieme Cerchiamo cerchiamo il ladro
cerchiamo il ladro Ladro ladro che se lo
chiamiamo Magari esce Ladro Dove sei
Ma come può essere questo codice li sto
provando tutti tutti più complicati 915
1919 milioni ma non funziona niente
questi sono troppo forti Chissà che
codice difficile si
apre devo stare zitto stanno venendo a
cercarmi Magari qui dentro c'è qualcosa
qualcuno eh E tu chi sei Che cosa ci fai
qua eh sono un ladro e mi sto
nascondendo Ah
ok
tranquillo Quindi avete trovato qualcuno
io non ho trovato niente neanch'io e tu
Eh no io solo un ladro che era sotto le
scale che si stava nascondendo un ladro
sotto le scale eh stavamo cercando non
l'hai fermato e si stava nascondendo Oh
mi sa che mi hanno trovato Andiamo ti
farò licenziare
andiamo Ecco è qui
Guardate il ladro il ladro e non lo so
chiediamolo sei il ladro sì me l'avi
detto prima che è il ladro No no non
sono un ladro sono un gatto
miao gatto Allora io non ho gatti e
allora ha il ladro sei il ladro oppure
sei un gatto ladro
arresto l'
arrestato Uff fa miene arrestata non ce
l'ho fatta Però la prossima volta non
dirò che sono un ladro Eh per forza sono
troppo
stupido e ora non ci resta che
restituire le cose a lei Anche questa è
sua signora grazie eh voi due non me
l'aspettavo siete stati bravi vi daremo
cinque stelle
abbiamo superato anche questo lavoro
Grazie grazie anche i poliziotti
l'abbiamo superato ma ora passiamo
subito al prossimo
Ciao In che lavoro sono finita Oh no
Vitale non è qua Questo vuol dire che
lui ha preso un altro ruolo
Maestra
d'asilo
d'asilo Ma dove sono i bambini qua non
c'è
nessuno
Ah questo bambino è
[Applauso]
fastidiosissimo Oh no ancora loro e ora
sono bambini piccoli Sarà difficilissimo
superare questa Challenge della maestra
d'asilo Ehi ma c'è anche una bambina lì
andiamo a vedere com'è Oh Che carina
questa bambina sembra tanto buona al
contrario di quell'altro bambino così
sarà più facile che carina che
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sei mia bsa oh no questi bambini sono
terribili Devo trovare il modo di
prendere cinque stelle e non essere
licenziata da qua Speriamo che rimangano
zitti e buoni nelle culle non riescono a
uscire dalle culle i bambini piccoli
no oh no e ritorna subito nella culla
torna nella culla dai no Dove state
andando Aspetta non scappare Non
scappare no no no no no no no no no oh
no
ASP aspetta giocate con le palline
guardate le palline le palline giocate
con questo
guarda
Aiuto Oh no mi hanno legata Ma dovevi
Dale quando serve
aiuto Vitale
Aiuto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Aiuto no no no no no Fatevi del male
allora il mio obiettivo qua è riuscire a
fargli fare un riposino ma mi sembrano
troppo svegli questi bambini ho
fatto Oh no ma io non voglio poire la
cacca di nessuno almeno La cosa positiva
è che questi bambini sembra che siano
piccoli Quindi ancora non camminano
vero non camino n Ma che razza di
B
aiuto
aiuto aiuto
aiuto Fermi Raffa non li figate fermi No
non prendete quello no Fermi Fermi devo
fare in modo che non vi fate del male
con la vostra
maestra
aiuto questi bambini sto terribili Come
però foni fare il riposino sono pieni di
energia aiuto no no no no prendere quell
dai ahi aiuto ma dov'è Vale quando serve
Basta io scappo via lascio la
[Musica]
Challenge No non posso lasciarli qua o
si faranno del
male no
poverina poverina
Mao
non voglio fare questo lavore non ce la
faccio
[Musica]
Aiuto Dai tranquilla non piangete perché
non fate un riposino
adesso Ehi Ehi ma cosa sta succedendo
aiuto Michele Chi sono questi
bambini siamo dei maestri d'asilo in
questo lavoro dei maestri d'asilo ma è
facilissimo sono solo dei bambini non è
facilissimo per niente questi bambini
sembrano degli bestie Ma che dici sono
solo dei bambini che cosa vuoi che ti
facciano lo scoprirei molto presto io
scappo Ma cosa ci vorrà mai a gestire
due bambini bambini Cosa state
[Applauso]
facendo Ma che cosa non si fanno queste
cose bambini non Ahia
ahia facendo non si fanno queste cose ma
St
facendo Ahia sono qua per difendermi
io
capitale
tu Te l'avevo detto che sono delle
bestie questi bambini come facciamo a
gestirli dobbiamo fargli fare il
riposino non è impossibile il riposino
Ma come fai a farli riposare questi Ah
aiuto Magari possiamo dare dobbiamo
elaborare un piano sì ah CTI facciamoci
scudo con questo ho un'idea prepariamo
un Fortino contro i bambini Sì
nascondiamoci qua dentro entra e poi
elaboriamo un piano per farli
addormentare Va bene ok Ma dove sei
finito
Aho Aspetta ho trovato un Fortino
migliore questo vediamo se ci stiamo qua
dentro Ok
allora così qua sono al sicuro dai
bambini
piccoli Ah ma ci posso crere io qua non
capisco dove sto non tu non Sieni qua
dentro Io ho questo mi difendo con
questo va bene Aiuto Aiuto Una capilla
iamo Pilla a questi bambini Buona idea
Potremmo provare a
farare
Aiuto
Aiuto scuno Si
salvi
Quest aiuto cos
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ora che sembra che si siano calmati Ho
un'idea Prova a preparargli
qu ma cosa stai facendo Ti sei
trasformata anche tu in
bambino loro non sapevo come fare prova
a preparargli qualcosa da mangiare
magari con il cibo si calmeranno così
come ti calmi Tu con il cibo Ottima idea
non ci avevo pensato dai Porta subito
qualcosa da mangiare io qua Cerco di
difendermi che cosa gli posso portare
una lasagna o uno sforato di patate no
qualcosa per bambini dai sbrigati Ah sì
sì ce lo adesso presto Adesso vado
aspetta Spero di riuscire a resistere
qua da sola Sono
duea
fregate Spero che questo Forino
reca vita
sgti
aiuto questi bambini sono
terribili Ma quando si staccheranno
[Musica]
[Applauso]
spale che cosa è successo
B
[Musica]
Pra tutti Aiuto Ho preparato per voi
untimo passato di
verdure Bravissimo Vale proviamo da
mangiare così forse si calmeranno una
volta per
tutte
[Musica]
eora silenzio un momento Questa è l'ora
della pappa adesso li faccio mangiare
così Speriamo che dopo che mangiano
saranno Abbastanza stanchi di
addormentarsi Tu nel frattempo prepara
le culle per farli dormire preparare le
curle subito perché solo se riusciamo a
farli addormentare avremo cinque stelle
avremo vinto la Challenge Eh tu tu
occupati del cibo adesso Eh sì Ora li
faccio mangiare Sì sì io vado
Allora Che schifo Che cosa hai
combinato aspetta si mangia con i
cucchiai Allora per chi è questa
e no che cosa avete
fatto che scha
Aspetta non si mangia
cos non aspetta no non si mangia
così Che
schifo Non si mangia così il passato di
perur aiuto
viole di passato diore Aiutami tu Io
vado io vado a pulirmi
Prova tu a farli mangiare queste besti
Allora Fermi
tutti Io voglio sapere una cosa Perché
state combinando
questo ho capito Hanno detto che non gli
piace quindi è buono o
[Applauso]
nook Ok ok adesso che casino che avete
fatto Ok adesso ad Adesso lo assaggio io
Eh Vediamo se è così terribile come
dicono è buono è
buono Vabbè non c'è problema me lo
mangio io ho capito Ho
[Applauso]
[Musica]
capito Fai questo te no Oh così posso
mangiare in santa
pace e come
invitare Sei riuscito a farli
addormentare Sì ma non gridare senò ti
svegliano Bravissimo Ma come hai fatto e
praticamente non volevano mangiare l'ho
mangiata io la passato di verdur E
allora gli ho dato il ciuccio Sì sempre
il solito Manzone però ha funzionato Sì
si sono addormentati Questo significa
che abbiamo superato anche questo lavoro
Sì cinque stelle abbiamo visto questa
Challenge voi lasciate un bel mi piace
Mi raccomando scriveteci in commento con
il vostro momento preferito Se volete
avere la possibilità di essere salutati
nei prossimi video e cliccate mi piace
Ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro celline su
qui ficare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e